- Did y'all do anything like to bond
while y'all were shooting this?
'Cause it's a trilogy.
I feel like you're like
the Avengers of Hallmark.
This is awesome.
- Oh, we were so excited to be together
and have this chance,
and we knew each other
in different ways before,
and now I feel forever bonded to them.
But I mean, everything from,
we'd finish work and be like,
"Do you wanna come work on some lines
and have a glass of wine?"
And that would turn into five hours later
we'd be in our pajamas,
just having girls' night.
- Love that kind of night.
- I'm not sure, we ran a
lot of lines to be honest.
(all laughing)
I drank wine and talked about parenting
and just bonded,
and had a good time some lot of laughs.
- That's important though
'cause we all are parents
and it's a hard thing to be a working mom.
- It is. I've learned so
much from these ladies.
I have just the utmost
respect so we're very lucky.
- Yeah, yeah, it's a big job.
So Autumn, these guys changed your mind
about one parenting decision, right?
- They did, they were so
passionate about Disneyland
and the experience of taking your kids
to Disneyland.
- [Kelly] Wait.
- Which is something I
hadn't done with my sons yet.
- Wait, what?
- The crowds and the expense
and they convinced me
and I took my kids to Disneyland
for New Year's this year.
That was our big New Year's celebration.
- Kelly, we had the exact same reaction.
We were floored.
- And I loved it.
- I feel like Lacey almost
fell out of her chair
when she found out
- [Lacey] I did.
I was like, how have you
never been to Disneyland?
- [Kelly] That's like where you take kids
when you're here.
- I'm not judging you
but, also, how have you
never been to Disneyland?
- Also yeah, wait, you'd never been?
- I'd been, but I hadn't taken my kids.
I hadn't taken that big parenting leap.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Well, it is a fun parenting leap
because no matter who you
are, you have a meltdown
with a child at some point during the day.
- [Autumn] Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you question so many life decisions.
- Everything.
- [Kelly] Aha, everything.
And you're like, why are we here?
And then it's like, why
did I have this idea?
This is supposed to be fun.
- [Autumn] So much sugar.
(all laughing)
- Kind of what if the
sugar is Satan (chuckles).
- When you see your kids watch "Fantasmic"
for the first time, I just
still can picture it in my mind.
Like, just the beauty of it
and the adventure and the
like look on their face.
It was like, I was seven years old again.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, it's magical.